ja willkommen zur ersten Sendung im
Rahmen des Seminars Immanuel Kant
Grundlegung zu Metapher in diese ersten
Sendung soll es um die Hintergründe von
dieser Schrift gehen es ist eine sehr
sehr kompakte Schrift die Immanuel Kant
im Jahr 1785 veröffentlicht hat nach
seiner Kritik der reinen Vernunft das
ist eine sehr umfangreiches Werk welches
vier Jahre zuvor erschienen war und die
Grundlegung zu metaphasiten die geht der
ebenfalls etwas umfangreicheren der
praktischen fünf voran die erst 1788
erschien dieses Werk eignet sich ganz
hervorragend um ihn kannst Ethik
einzusteigen nicht nur in ganzetik
sondern überhaupt in die Ethik
grundsätzlich
seine Grundlegung zu metaphythesiten die
enthält komprimiert seine
Grundeinsichten zur Moralphilosophie sie
ist auch eine der bekanntesten Werke
die allermeisten Studierende der
Philosophie haben damit schon mal zu tun
gehabt nicht nur Studierende sondern
alle anderen Philosophie Interessierte
die Grundfrage dieses Werks lautet wie
können wir eine Ethik nur durch Vernunft
begründen die absolute Geltungsanspruch
hat ohne dabei auf Erfahrung angewiesen
zu sein Erfahrung mein bekannt
empirisches also Gefühle Neigungen
individuelle Zustände das soll nach kann
keine Rolle spielen bei der Begründung
der Ethik deswegen wird ganz Ethik auch
eine vernünftig genannt oder auch eine
die ontologische Ethik die ontologische
Ethik bedeutet eine pflichtig eine Ethik
die nicht so sehr wie die Tugend Ethik
oder der Utilitarismus
sich entweder mit Charaktereigenschaften
oder mit dem Nutzen von Handlungen
befasst sondern mit der Frage inwiefern
eine Handlung oder genau genommen eine
Handlungsmotivation der Pflicht der
moralischen Pflicht entspricht oder auch
nicht und dabei steht wegen dieser
Pflicht Ethik wegen dieser deontologie
auch ein Imperativ im Zentrum der
kategorische Imperativ jetzt stellt sich
die Frage für diese Schrift wie können
wir diesen kategorischen Imperativ diese
Vernunft Pflicht augenanforderungen
Aufforderung wie können wir die
begründen und zwar aus reiner Vernunft
unabhängig von Erfahrung und wie können
wir diesen kategorischen Imperativ
dieses Kriterium der
Sittlichkeit wie Manuel kann sagt auf
konkrete Situationen in unserem Alltag
anwenden
weitere wichtige Begriffe von ganz Ethik
sind
metaphysiten und der heutigen Sitzung
soll es um diesen Begriff vorangehen der
Wille Freiheit Autonomie der Begriff ist
damit auch Verbundenheit zu viel
Selbstgesetzgebung Heteronomie der
Gegenbegriff fremdgesetzgebung
Fremdbestimmung und die reine praktische
fünf ist auch zentral dann den Begriff
Pflicht hatte ich schon genannt er ist
auch sehr sehr zentral
die habe ich alle angeführt und jetzt
wollen wir uns wieder Frage befassen was
eigentlich eine Metaphysik ist
grundsätzlich müssen wir zwischen Ethik
und Moral bzw Sitten unterscheiden also
auf der einen Seite die Ethik auf der
anderen Seite die Moral oder die Sitten
unter Moral und Sitten verstehen wir im
gesellschaftlichen gültige und
geforderte Verhaltensweisen im Umgang
miteinander
es gehört sich dass man das und das tut
dass man so und so miteinander umgeht
das ist die Moral
Moral und Sitten sind also normativ sie
beschreiben nicht nur wie in
Gesellschaft gehandelt wird sondern auch
wie man darin handeln soll
die Moral bzw die Sitten können müssen
aber nicht
festgelegt sein auf eine schriftliche
Art können sich auch bloß
gewohnheitsmäßig addieren
oder sonst manifestieren sie müssen also
nicht in einem Art von Gesetz
niedergeschrieben sein es kann sich auch
um eine mündliche Ethik Tradition
handelt
dagegen die reflektiert auf die Moral
oder die Sitten also auf diese
Handlungsregeln die normative also
verbindliche sollens Geltung haben und
sie versucht diese Moral oder die sind
objektiv zu bestimmen und zu begründen
und zwar auf verschiedene Weisen
deontologisch Pflicht ethisch wie wir
schon bis ganz gesehen haben
konsequentialistisch wenn es um die
Konsequenzen geht oder tugenetisch wenn
es um den Charakter der anderen Person
geht dann handelt es sich um normative
Ethik es gibt auch noch die Metaethik
und die bedeutet so viel dass nur
untersucht wird wie über Moral und sie
sind gesprochen wird nicht normativ
nicht verbindlich im handelnden Sinne
Formen sind sondern bezüglich der
Begriffe die dabei verwendet werden wie
z.B der Begriff gut welche Bedeutung
kann gut alles haben dann sind wir auf
der Ebene der Mitte
kann versteht jetzt unter seine Ethik
Anknüpfung an die antike Tradition eine
Wissenschaft eine strenge Wissenschaft
von der Ural ob es sowas gibt eine
Wissenschaftler Moral das ist natürlich
strickig kann sagt die Ethik als
Wissenschaftler Moral oder der sieben
ist genauso wissenschaftlich wie die
Physik oder die Logik und deswegen
vergleicht das sie auch damit
während sich jetzt die Physik mit
Gegenständen befasst die den Naturgesetz
unterliegen die im Wandel und stehen
begriffen sind handelt es sich bei der
Ethik um eine Wissenschaft die sich mit
dem Sittengesetz also mit dem
pflichtgebot mit einem Gesetz befasst
was unsere Handlungen betrifft und nicht
nur die Natur Ereignisse und dieses
Gesetz ist letztendlich auch angesetzt
der Freiheit weil wir frei sein müssen
um überhaupt unsere Handlung zu führen
Verantwortung gezogen werden zu können
ja jetzt kann man sich fragen was ist
eigentlich eine metaphysiken ganz hat
die Ethik wie er sie versteht die darf
keine empirische Wissenschaft sein die
sollen nicht abhängig sein von
psychologischen Erkenntnissen oder von
Wechsel den Zeitumständen sondern es
soll sich dabei um eine reine
Philosophie handeln und rein bedeutet
bekannt dass sie abiori ist Apriori
heißt vor allem Erfahrung also aus
reiner Vernunft Moral begründen das ist
das Projekt seiner Metapher
grenzt sich dabei von praktischer
Anthropologie ab damit meine
letztendlich empirische Lehre vom
Menschen wie Du mal der Mensch ist wir
erscheint wir bislang gewesen ist dass
er kann das genügt nicht humoral
Objektiv so begründen wir brauchen also
eine Metaphysik der sie
sie besteht darin jenseits der Physik
sowie auch das Wort Metaphysik das
anzeigt
unabhängig vom Bereich des natürlichen
was immer entsteht und vergeht absolut
gültigen Normen für unser Handeln so
begründen und aufzuweisen und das ist
nach Kante Instanz der reinen
praktischen Vernunft
wie können wir also fragt jetzt kann nur
durch Nachdenken nur durch
Vernunftgebrauch erkennen und was so
erkennen dass es normative Gültigkeit
und bindende Kraft hat wie wir handeln
sollen und wie wir nicht handelszahlen
das ist die spannende Frage die sich
kann stellt und kann
vermutet und zeigt dann auch dass es
möglich ist eine solche Metapher sind
durch reine Vernunft zu entwickeln das
waren jetzt erste Anmerkung du kannst
Projekt einer metaphysiken in der
nächsten Folge gehen wir dann weiter und
behandeln uns mit ganz begriffen des
Willens und auch seinen Begriff der
Vernunft